welcome back everyone this is the hero
daily we have officially reached uh the
first milestone which is 500 subscribers
i know it seems like a little bit
compared to other huge channels that
have been doing this for a while but i
am officially a little more than 500 i
would love to get to a thousand so if
you haven't already please hit subscribe
i am doing this every day uh here on the
channel we've been doing a lot of doctor
strange and multiverse of madness uh
plot leaks lately and it's been very fun
to see what that movie is going to turn
out into and definitely not spoiling it
entirely because most of the plot leaks
do not give us the ending
in its entirety and i believe at least
from my understanding even the most
legitimate leaks that i've seen out
there do not touch on apparently all the
uh variants and cameos that we will be
seeing in the movie so it is very
exciting even though that we do know
for the most part what the entire movie
is going to be about that we're not
seeing every single detail which makes
it very fun still to
uh simply speculate on who is still
going to be showing up uh who is
essentially going to be playing a small
little cameo
when it comes to these variants and
whatnot i know that tom cruise has been
named many times so far and in terms of
official confirmations uh i haven't
heard anything but i know that we do
have those pictures uh that haven't
necessarily been confirmed and whatnot
but let me tell you that there is
another leak coming for tom cruise and
that is that he has apparently gone in
to do a post credit scene
and spoiler alert what we've seen in the
plot leaks is that wanda does end up
killing most of the illuminati members
and that is including charles xavier
himself
so we do have that post-credits scene
which is most likely going to be setting
up a new multiversal illuminati with our
doctor strange which is exciting because
as most of you know the illuminati in
the comics does include doctor strange
himself and so far the plot leaks do not
have a secondary or a variant doctor
strange a part of the illuminati that we
will be seeing in doctor strange
multiverse of madness anyways uh
pre-sale tickets have officially been
announced to go on sale as april 6 and
that is officially a month from the
release date and i recommend watching on
the day of because that is probably the
best
audience that you will ever see because
it is the most passionate
mcu
fan base that you can actually get in
one room who will go out of their way to
get these pre-sale tickets and watch the
movie on the day of and let me tell you
that for those of you who
saw spider-man no way home on the day of
it is definitely
an entirely different theater going
experience as to going a couple weeks
after when you have everyone cheering
for the huge moments that will be
happening in the movie uh this is very
similar to most mcu projects that have
been released on the scale which is
similar to infinity war end game you
know uh spider-man no way home and of
course now we have doctor strange the
multiverse abandons but anyways please
do me a favor hit that like button uh
please subscribe if you haven't and i'll
see you guys tomorrow thank you so much
for listening